Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
One of the things that
everyone does
in lie of a big event, a big time that's
going to come and pass, a special time
is we make
resolutions to ourselves.
Resolutions. We say
that when this time comes to pass, I'm
going to be or I'm going to do or I'm
not going to do etc.
And this is normal. There's nothing
wrong with this per se.
However,
the reason that these things don't often
come through
and they usually fall apart
and
they usually are not met. These goals
are not met and achieved
is because the goals that are set
are one of two things.
They're either
too big
or they're too vague.
What am I speaking about? Well, of
course, we understand
that
Ramadan is very close.
It's coming in couple weeks inshallah.
And everyone
has certain resolutions that we make.
We want to be better.
We want to change things about
ourselves.
We want to do better.
And so
we make these resolutions
and we make these solemn oaths with
ourselves and oftentimes with Allah
that when Ramadan comes this year, I'm
going to do X, Y, and Z and I'm not
going to do X, Y, and Z and I'm going to
be and so forth.
So
again, everyone does this. That's fine.
The problem is is how many times is it
actually followed through with
rarely.
And the reason
is because the goal is too big
or the goal is too
vague.
It's not clear. You don't have a set
plan.
Imagine if I
thought or if I decided I'm going to
take a trip to Phoenix
and
I don't prepare myself before the trip,
but on the day of the trip, I just wake
up, jump in the car, and start driving.
I drive whatever direction
feels the best direction.
I drive whichever direction feels best.
I don't have a map.
I don't have a plan.
I don't have
myself prepared for that. I just jump in
the car and start driving. But I'm
really really have I have a very good
intention. My intention is super pure. I
have no ulterior motives. My only
intention is to get there.
And I drive really fast and really hard.
I do it really good.
What are the chances that I'm going to
get there?
Very, very slim.
This is the problem that we often are
faced with.
we get to Ramadan,
we want to take this trip.
But instead of us preparing properly,
instead of us
having a plan,
having a reasonable plan,
having a detailed plan,
we just jump in the car and start
driving around.
And so a lot of us don't get there.
Change is something that is incremental.
Any real change, fundamental change,
it's incremental. It's over time.
How long did it take Allah to create the
heavens and the earth? How many days?
[Arabic recitation]
ta'ala not have just created the heavens
and the earth and just have them pop
into existence ready to go?
[Silence]
Allah describes himself
If he desires something, if he wills
something, he says to it, "Be and it is,
but instead he created the heavens and
the earth in six days
over time."
And he made it a point to tell us this
throughout the Quran,
six days
to teach us the nature of this world.
This world is not a sudden thing. Things
don't just pop in and out of existence.
Behavior has to be learned.
I want you to imagine
your time and who you become in Ramadan
a muscle
that you're trying to make stronger,
which is the case for any discipline.
You can't just immediately
wake up stronger, wake up different. If
I wanted to
start to lift weights or I wanted to
start to train for something, I can't
just go in the weight room, put as much
weight on the machines as I possibly
can, and work myself to to bits.
That's not sustainable.
And it doesn't really help anything in
the long run. As a matter of fact, it'll
most likely hurt me. It'll make me sick.
And the next time I think about working
out, that's going to be daunting,
nightmarish, leaves a bad taste in my
mouth. That's not how we achieve things.
When we are approaching Ramadan now,
many of us have these resolutions.
Number one,
and we're going to take three points.
The first point,
you don't have to wait for Ramadan to
start
for you to start being who you're
promising to be.
You don't have to wait till Ramadan
starts.
I'm going to read the Quran every day.
I'm going to pray at night. I'm going to
do this and that. You don't have to wait
till Ramadan. You can start right now.
And as a matter of fact, if you want to
make it through Ramadan doing these
things that you are hoping to do and
accomplishing them,
you need to start now.
You need to start now changing those
habits and changing the routine so that
by the time Ramadan comes, you are
already in that routine.
That's number one.
So the first point,
you don't have to wait till Ramadan
to do these things. Number two
is the plan or the goal is too big.
It's too big.
If a plan is too big and too vague, it's
not going to usually be obtained.
My plan can't just be I want to be a
good Muslim.
Great. That's, you know, everybody wants
that. But how am I going to do that? I
want to go to Jenna. Fantastic. What is
your plan to get there? Not just general
specific plan to get to paradise. What
is it?
Which door of the doors of paradise are
you are you aiming for? How many doors
of paradise are there?
How many?
[Arabic recitation]
are these doors of paradise for?
Each one. Yes.
[Arabic recitation]
characteristics that a person embodies.
You have a door for salah. For the
people that excel in salah, you have a
door for zak. You have a door or
charity. You have a door for fasting.
For those who are most excellent at
fasting,
which one of those doors do you have
your eye on? You should have one, there
should be one of those doors that you
are planning to go through.
If your plan to get to Jenna is just I
want to go to Jenna, inshallah,
fantastic. That's
that's a great plan. I mean, that's a
great goal, but it's not a realistic
goal.
Anyone who has a realistic goal
knows that the goal has details. What
are the details?
What are you going to do in the first
year? What are you going to do in the
first five years? Where what do you want
to be doing in the next 10 years? What's
your plan? What's the exact way that
you're going to get there?
This is
paramount importance
that a person
have a goal that's reasonable
and a goal that's detailed.
And often times we jump the gun and we
start too big.
We want to wear 10 hats at the same
time.
But that's not how it works.
We don't need to wear 10 hats. We just
need to wear one really well.
And we need to start
at the basics.
Let me ask a question.
What is the real spirit of fasting?
What's the real point of fasting?
Is it
about
not eating and not drinking? Is that
really the point of fasting?
Well, then what is it?
What is fasting for? What are you
fasting for?
It's not
[Silence]
That's not the point.
The point is tawa.
It's for you to learn tawa.
And tapa starts
with
the basics.
Let's say
I were
fasting in the day of Ramadan
and I forget
and you know out of habit I get thirsty.
I go to the sink. I pour a glass of
water and I drink it. And then I
remember, oh goodness, I I'm fasting.
What do I do?
Tell us, Miriam,
you still fast. Did I break my fast by
doing that?
Cuz I forgot, right? Okay, that was a
glass of water. Let's say
I'm fasting.
I get really hungry and I forget that
I'm fasting
and I jump in my car and I drive to the
gas station and I buy
a Snickers bar and I eat it and I enjoy
it.
Am I still fasting or not?
I forgot.
I only remembered after I finished
eating it. Am I still fasting or not?
[Arabic recitation]
forgot. I forgot.
You get hungry.
You got a minute, right?
And
I go ahead and eat a candy bar.
Yes. Miam. Again.
I forgot.
And then I remembered after. Am I still
fasting? Yes.
[Arabic recitation]
enjoyed it. So, I have to drink the
glass of water hating it.
When I'm drinking it, I have to be
thinking, "Man, I hate this water. I
hate this candy bar. I wish I I wish
candy bars never existed."
Is that it?
[Arabic recitation]
H I mean there's no difference between
the first question and the second
question. The answer is I'm still what?
[Arabic recitation]
I'm still fasting because I forgot.
Okay, here's another question.
I get hungry and I'm fasting and I
forgot
and I go to the buffet
and I eat a five course meal.
[Arabic recitation]
Nobody reminded me. I'm I'm living alone
and to me it's just a regular day. I
jumped in the car, went to the buffet,
and I ate and I ate and I ate and I ate.
And then at the last bite,
you know, at the buffet, you you finish
everything and then you've got your
dessert,
you've got your ice cream, you've got
whatever, and then I'm looking there and
I've got one last bite of my dessert
left.
And then I remember, oh my goodness, I'm
fasting.
[Arabic recitation]
As soon as I remembered, I stopped.
The answer is yes. I'm still fasting
because I forgot. I mean, it's unlikely.
It's an unlikely scenario,
but that's the ruling.
A guy goes into the market, buys a bag
of grapes,
forgets, he's eating, eating. He gets to
the last grape and he says, "Oh man, I'm
fasting."
But then he's not going to throw this
one grape away.
Right? There's one grape. I've already
ate a pound.
[Arabic recitation]
broke his fast?
of grapes. The last grape broke his
fast.
So what do we understand from that? When
when the prophet tells us sallallahu
alaihi wasallam
that if you forget and eat or drink
something then continue fasting because
Allah
has fed you. That's what he said. That's
what the prophet said. If you forgot
then it's Allah that fed you.
But why would Allah feed you while
you're supposed to be fasting?
The answer is that fasting is not about
what?
Eating and drinking.
That's just the bare minimum.
That's not the real spirit of fasting.
Fasting is not about eating and
drinking. Fasting,
true fasting
is about
not doing something that is haram during
your day of fasting.
Now let's take the same question.
Let's say a person is fasting and
forgets
and then
does something haram while he's fasting.
forgot he was fasting.
Then he started to backbite someone
or he started to slander someone or he
told a lie
or he looked at something haram
or he stole something
or he hurt somebody while he was
fasting.
Does
this person still get a sin for that?
Do you do you still have a sin written
against you for doing that? Even if you
forgot,
yes.
So if you're fasting and you forget and
eat something, no sin. But if you're
fasting and you forget and disobey
Allah, the sin is written against you.
Why? Because that's the point of
fasting.
Listen to this narration. We only got a
couple minutes left. Listen to this
narration. Our prophet Sam,
he said
true fasting
is not
to just fast
from eating and drinking.
True fasting
is
to not
do something haram
or do something
that is unproductive.
That's what true fasting is.
True fasting is that you don't do what
is haram.
So let's say
our
allegiance or our
Ramadan
resolution
instead of our Ramadan resolution being
I'm going to turn into a saint this
Ramadan. I'm going to read the Quran 10
times.
I'm going to make salah all night.
I'm going to do this and that. What
about
if our
resolution was just
I am not going to do anything that I
know to be haram this Ramadan while I am
fasting. No bad habits. Anything that I
know that is haram, I'm going to not do
it while I'm fasting. And I am not going
to do anything
that is unproductive
while I'm fasting. That's a waste of
time. That will kill time.
I'm only going to do that which is
productive
and that which is halal.
If a person did this,
how much would they change during this
month of Ramadan?
I mean, honestly, really change.
And that's really what the point of
Ramadan is.
Fasting is only one part of Ramadan.
Fasting is just so that you can
get purified from sins so that when the
nighttime comes and you hear the Quran,
it will reach parts of your heart that
were otherwise in darkness. That's the
point of Ramadan.
I mean, listen to this. And
isn't it interesting that Allah
described the month of Ramadan?
He said Ramadan.
So he said the month of Ramadan in which
the Quran was revealed.
It's strange because when Ramadan is
mentioned, we usually think about
fasting, right?
But that's not what Allah described it
as. If you were to describe something,
you describe it what by what it's most
known for.
It wasn't described as the month of
fasting.
It was described as the month of the
Quran.
That means that fasting is only a part
of it.
Ramadan is really about the Quran and
all this fasting in the daytime. It's to
purify you,
to expedate sin,
to get you out of your comfort zone, to
shake your world up a little bit, so
that when you nighttime comes and you
hear the Quran,
it's coming upon a pure and regenerated
heart, a purified heart. That's the
whole point of Ramadan.
And so if you were to just take an oath
that I will not do anything haram,
I'll try my best. Everybody makes
mistakes, but I try my best
during the daylight hours to break all
those bad deeds, all those bad habits
during the fasting hours
and then just come to salah and listen
to the Quran.
You have done more than most people
could ever hope to achieve during
Ramadan.
So
we'll talk about next week
about
some rulings with respect to Ramadan.
This week we wanted to just really
think about what the point of this month
is to prepare ourselves in the right way
so that if we don't keep making
resolutions that we break just like
you know people make New Year's
resolutions
this year I'm going to lose weight and
then they get fatter that year.
this this year I'm going to
settle down and get married and then or
I'm going to fix my marriage. They end
up getting divorced that year or this
year I'm going to learn a skill and they
end up becoming more lazy than they ever
have in any previous year. Why? Because
the plan is too vague. because
there was no detail to the plan. And
number three, they waited until the new
year to start. If you want to start
something, you start now. Practice now.
By the time it comes, you will ease into
it. You don't just go to sleep on the
last night of Shaen and wake up the next
day and all of the sudden everything
changes. That's not how change happens.
not meaningful change anyways. So we
will take a stop there inshallah we
have some other things going on program
but next week we'll have some of the
rulings of Ramadan. If you have any
questions and Friday night is about the
youngsters. If you have any questions,
prepare them for next week inshallah.
[Silence]
I have a question. So, last time I I
slept in the I slept in the shower and
she wouldn't keep volume about 10 of
them.
[Arabic recitation]